son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
el gobierno y la oposición de Venezuela
reanudarán diálogos este viernes así lo
anunció el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro las conversaciones estaban
suspendidas desde octubre de 2021 luego
de que Alexa presunto testaferro del
presidente Nicolás Maduro pues es
extraditado a Estados Unidos tenemos
análisis en esta emisión
Rusia lanzó un nuevo ataque masivo de
misiles contra Ucrania según kiev 67
proyectiles fueron disparados pero las
fuerzas ucranianas lograron derribar 51
esto mientras que en terreno diplomático
el parlamento europeo declaró a Rusia
estado promotor del terrorismo lo que
fue celebrado por el presidente de
Ucrania
la justicia británica dictaminó que el
gobierno de Escocia no puede convocar un
nuevo referendo de autodeterminación si
la autorización del ejecutivo británico
ya en 2014 este territorio dijo no a la
independencia en una consulta en la que
el rechazo obtuvo un 55%.
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio hablando de Venezuela
porque este viernes se retomarán las
conversaciones entre el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro y la oposición venezolana
así lo informó el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro quien lo anunció de forma
escueta a través de su cuenta de Twitter
los diálogos quedaron congelados en 2021
cuando El Ejecutivo de Caracas se
levantó de la mesa en protesta por la
extradición a Estados Unidos de alexap
un presunto testaferro de maduro para
analizar esta situación conectamos Con
Román Ibarra él es abogado especialista
en gobierno y políticas públicas y
profesor universitario en derecho y
ciencia política Bienvenido a Francia 24
Cuál es la importancia de retomar estos
diálogos
Bueno dialogar siempre es interesante
porque permite conversar para negociar y
llegar a acuerdos tanto el gobierno del
presidente Maduro que está muy
interesado en que le levantan las
sanciones y el gobierno de los Estados
Unidos muy interesado en conseguir a la
brevedad petróleo y gas barato y seguro
a vida cuenta de que Rusia producto de
las sanciones que ellos y los europeos
impusieron producto de la invasión de
Rusia a Ucrania ya no puede encontrar
con el suministro de petróleo ni de gas
en el caso europeo es presidente byden
con mucha astucia y con mucho
pragmatismo está intentando negociar con
el gobierno del presidente maduro a
objeto de que se reinicie las
negociaciones Solo que hay un detalle
estas negociaciones en México es con un
sector de la oposición no con toda la
oposición y este sector de la oposición
en el caso venezolano tiene
contrapartida con los partidos
judicializados por el gobierno del
presidente maduro cuya titularidad le
fue otorgada a los adversarios de estos
que van a reunirse en México Total que
demuestra con ellos una gran astucia el
presidente maduro porque en el exterior
reconoce a esta comisión o a este sector
de la oposición y en el caso venezolano
reconoce como autoridades de los
partidos políticos a otros que son
adversarios de estos hay un gran enredo
en la en la política venezolana porque
la oposición está dividida y está
dividida no solo por la astucia del
presidente maduro sino por la por los
propios errores cometidos por la
oposición en el sentido de haber
sistematizado la convocatoria a la
abstención a pesar de que muchísimos les
dijimos que ese era un camino errado y
totalmente
destructor de las posibilidades de la
oposición venezolana todas las encuestas
dicen que el presidente maduro tiene un
apoyo muy precario y sin embargo sigue
controlando todo porque todas las
instituciones le fueron regaladas
gracias a la abstención el gobierno del
presidente maduro en este caso
tiene mucho que ganar porque si le
levantan las sanciones va a poder
recuperar parcialmente la economía y
avanzar en la recuperación de otros
sectores que ellos mismos destruyeron
Pero cuando la oposición controlaba la
asamblea nacional que pudo haber ayudado
o ayudado al gobierno en materia de
recuperación de servicios públicos
esenciales como la electricidad y el
agua no quiso hacerlo para que el
gobierno no ganara
rédito pero los organismos
internacionales como la corporación
andina de fomento ofrecieron recursos
para esa recuperación cosa que hay que
emprender en cualquier momento porque ya
el daño está producido Bueno y qué tanta
estabilidad y legitimidad podemos
esperar pues en estos diálogos de parte
del gobierno de maduro y también de la
oposición para que las conversaciones
prosperen
bueno porque quien está detrás de ese
sector de la oposición para que esas
conversaciones tengan relativo éxito es
nada más y nada menos que el gobierno de
los Estados Unidos es decir el mismo que
ha producido las sanciones que tanto
daño le están haciendo No al gobierno de
maduro sino a la población en general
entonces esa es una discusión que hay
que dar Con urgencia para que haya
salidas en el orden social y económico
para la recuperación repito de servicios
básicos desde niños que son esenciales
para el venezolano de a pie es decir en
Venezuela en este momento lo que era la
Joya de de los de los sistemas de metro
en toda América Latina en Venezuela fue
destruido por el gobierno y ahora hay
que recuperarlo no hay transporte
subterráneo no hay transporte
superficial no hay luz no hay agua no
hay un conjunto de de de sistemas
básicos que la población necesita con
absoluta urgencia
Bueno y qué papel jugará Colombia en
estos diálogos entre la oposición y el
gobierno de Venezuela la mediación y me
parece que es correcta No solamente la
del presidente Petro sino la del
presidente de Argentina y el presidente
de Francia que como ustedes vieron en la
Cumbre de Egipto se acercó a conversar
con el presidente maduro a objeto de
Buscar mecanismos de intermediación para
negociar de hecho ya se produjo una
reunión en París que conduce también a
esta digamos retoma de conversaciones en
el caso de México Dios quiera que todo
salga bien porque le conviene al país en
su conjunto porque lo que hay que frenar
es el deterioro que es muy profundo en
el caso venezolano a pesar de que en los
tiempos de la República civil como todos
sabemos Venezuela fue de los países más
prósperos de todo el hemisferio señor
Ibarra usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por compartirlo con nosotros
en francés 24 vamos ahora a Ucrania
porque este miércoles Rusia lanzó un
nuevo ataque masivo sobre territorio
ucraniano según las autoridades de kiev
Moscú 67 misiles pero las fuerzas
ucranianas derribaron 51 Rusia dirigió
30 de estos proyectiles sobre kiev donde
cinco personas perdieron la vida El
bombardeo múltiple también impactó un
hospital materno en zaporilla en materia
diplomática el parlamento europeo
declaró a Rusia como estado patrocinador
del terrorismo veamos el resumen de la
jornada en el informe de Juan Pablo
lucumí
una lluvia de misiles rusos en la
capital ucraniana en la tarde de este
miércoles las autoridades de kiev
informaron de ataques aéreos de Moscú
dejando muertos y heridos
Solo espero que todos estén bien pero vi
a la gente que están sacando del
edificio los que estaban heridos y no sé
si están vivos Pero espero que estén
bien
los bombardeos dañaron varias
estructuras eléctricas uno de los
objetivos públicamente declarados por
Moscú presuntamente para convertir el
frío y la oscuridad del invierno en un
arma estratégica Pero estos ataques
también complicaron la atención de
heridos en los hospitales que dependen
del generador de energía mientras esto
sucedía en kiev en Bruselas los
parlamentarios de la Unión Europea
declaraban a Rusia como estado
patrocinador del terrorismo avanzamos en
la resolución que reconoce a la
federación rusa como estado patrocinador
del terrorismo Alemania y chipre también
pidieron una detención inmediata de lo
que calificaron como bombardeos
terroristas de Rusia Mientras que el
presidente ucraniano aseguró que van a
recuperarse masivo ataque y agradeció el
apoyo de los aliados
el parlamento europeo finalmente
reconoció a Rusia como estado
patrocinador del terrorismo Gracias a
todos los parlamentarios y luego Rusia
demostró al mundo entero que esto es
cierto al usar 67 cohetes contra nuestra
infraestructura nuestra energía y gente
común
este miércoles Estados Unidos anunció
una concesión de 400 millones de dólares
adicionales en apoyo militar a Ucrania
con esta nueva ayuda Estados Unidos ha
concedido unos 19,700 millones de
dólares a Ucrania en asistencia de
seguridad desde que el presidente Joe
biden llegó a la casa blanca
en Reino Unido el tribunal supremo
dictaminó que el gobierno de Escocia no
puede convocar un nuevo referendo de
autodeterminación sin la aprobación de
Londres recordemos que en la votación de
2014 el rechazo a la independencia ganó
con un 55% de los votos sin embargo El
Ejecutivo nacionalista escocés considera
que el brexit ha revertido la situación
Andrés yo no se amplía
un golpe legal a las esperanzas del
partido Nacional escocés de celebrar
otro referéndum la Independencia el
próximo octubre el tribunal supremo del
Reino Unido a dictaminado por unanimidad
que la Facultad de convocar un
referéndum está reservada al parlamento
británico la primera ministra escocesa a
Nicolás Target dijo que respetaba la
sentencia del tribunal pero considera
que roja duda sobre la democracia dentro
del referéndulo de la devolución de
Escocia en el que hay una especie de
descentralización del poder de Londres
sobre edimburgo en cuanto a gasto social
o recaudación de impuestos
tal vez lo que la sentencia de hoy
confirma más que nada Es que la única
garantía de igualdad para Escocia dentro
de la familia británica de Naciones es
la independencia debemos encontrar y
encontraremos otro medio democrático
legal y constitucional para que el
pueblo escocés exprese su voluntad
dijo que convertiría las próximas
elecciones generales en una votación
facto sobre la separación del resto de
Reino Unido haciendo campaña únicamente
sobre esa premisa Mientras tanto el
Primer Ministro de Richard dio la
bienvenida al fallo creo que el pueblo
de Escocia quiere que trabajemos para
solucionar los principales retos a los
que nos enfrentamos colectivamente ya
sea la economía el apoyo al sistema de
salud o el apoyo a Ucrania ahora es el
momento de que los políticos trabajan
juntos
ha rechazado repetidamente que Escocia
celebre otro referéndum dice que el de
2014 en el que el 55% de los escoceses
rechazó la independencia San Jorge la
cuestión durante una generación pero el
Partido Nacional escocés Dice que ahora
hay un mandato indiscutible debido a una
mayoría que apoya la independencia en el
parlamento Escocia se vio obligada a
abandonar la Unión Europea junto al
resto de Reino Unido Pese a que la
mayoría de los escoceses votaron en
contra del brexit
vamos ahora a Jerusalén porque dos
bombas fueron detonadas en dos o
estaciones de autobús dejando un
fallecido de 16 años y 14 heridos según
lo informaron las autoridades ambas
explosiones fueron provocadas de forma
similar Pues los artefactos explosivos
que además contenían clavos estaban
dentro de bolsas y fueron detonados a
control remoto el Primer Ministro
saliente de Israel Yair la pida afirmó
que las fuerzas de seguridad trabajan
intensamente para capturar a los
responsables todavía tenemos una lucha
contra el terror brutal que vuelve a
levantar cabeza y haremos todo lo
posible para restaurar pronto la
seguridad de todos los ciudadanos de
Israel
quiero decir desde aquí a los ciudadanos
de Israel que alcanzaremos a los
perpetradores de los ataques pueden
correr pueden esconderse no los ayudará
las fuerzas de seguridad los alcanzarán
ante el aumento de los muros físicos y
administrativos para muchas personas la
única manera de migrar es a través de
rutas clandestinas sin embargo los
caminos migratorios espectaculares son
evidentemente mucho más peligrosos para
la vida de las personas que los viajes
regulares según un reciente en forma de
la organización internacional para las
migraciones desde 2014 50.000 migrantes
han muerto mientras se desplazaban de un
país a otro previamente hablamos con
Edwin viales de la oym con quien
conversamos sobre la influencia de la
industria de la defensa y de la
seguridad en la orientación de las
políticas migratorias
esto sin duda es esto un tema verdad el
todo el tema de la securitización de las
migraciones o de un enfoque punitivo o
de un enfoque policial hacia el abordaje
de las migraciones sin duda que es un
aliciente puede provocar fallecimientos
y desapariciones durante el tránsito
migratorio cuando se habla de temas
migratorios en general no solo de
personas migrantes fallecidas y
desaparecidas sin duda tanto los los
gobiernos y los diferentes entes
encargados de administrar las
migraciones en el mundo deben tener
presente que esté abortarse desde un
enfoque humanista verdad priorizando
siempre a las personas migrantes y sus
familias como centro de todos los
esfuerzos que se hagan y comprendiendo
también que la migración en muchos
sentidos entraña una oportunidad de
desarrollo para todas las naciones donde
llegan las personas migrantes que
atraviesan estas peligrosas rutas
en Haití al menos 202 personas han
perdido la vida a causa del cólera la
cifra supone un incremento de 15% en los
contagios con respecto a los números de
hace solamente una semana los más
afectados son los menores entre 1 y 4
años de edad con más de 2,250 casos
sospechosos y unos 170 confirmados la
mayoría de los contagios se concentra en
Puerto Príncipe la capital de Haití país
que además del brote de cólera hace
frente a una crisis humanitaria sin
precedentes así como la inestabilidad
política y la inseguridad
en la ciudad estadounidense de Nueva
York que se ultiman los preparativos
para el tradicional desfile de acción de
gracias que se llevará a cabo este 24 de
noviembre los organizadores Se esperan
que unas tres millones de personas vean
el evento en persona en total 16
inflables gigantes 28 carrozas 12 bandas
de música 700 payasos y Papá Noel
participarán en esta muestra Así
finalizamos esta emisión de directo
América aquí en France 24 a ustedes Les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a continuar con nosotros que ya llega a
Esther Herrera con Europa hoy Feliz
noche para todos
[Música]